c'est l'histoire d'une fuite colossal
gigantesque tentaculaire voilà qui
décrit l'ampleur du phénomène des
pandora peppers mais aussi l'anc est en
elle-même 600 journalistes 250 médias
répartis dans 117 pays ont analysé
pendant plusieurs mois près de 12
millions de données documents images
email des dossiers qui proviennent de
centres offshore et qui ont été transmis
au consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation par une
source anonyme les journalistes ont eu
accès aux archives de 14 cabinets
spécialisés dans les créations de
sociétés anonymes ils sont pour la
plupart disséminés dans des paradis
fiscaux ou belize îles vierges chypre ou
encore dubaï nous avons eu un accès
inédit à ce que représente l'évasion la
fraude ou l'optimisation fiscale dans le
monde des archives qui ont permis de
découvrir que parmi les dizaines de
milliers de propriétaires
d'établissements offshore 336 sont ou
ont été des personnalités politiques de
premier plan on retrouve ainsi abdallah
ii le roi de jordanie à la tête d'une
trentaine de sociétés offshore des
sociétés écrans qui lui ont notamment
permis d'acheter pas moins de 14
propriétés de luxe aux états unis et au
royaume uni direction la république
tchèque aussi jouent l'actuel premier
ministre andrés baby saurait financer
l'achat d'une propriété dans le sud de
la france grâce à quelques 22 millions
de dollars là aussi placés dans des
sociétés off shore réaction du principal
intéressé sur twitter je n'ai jamais
rien fait d'illégal ou de mal mais cela
ne les empêche pas d'essayer de me
dénigrer à nouveau et d'influencer les
élections législatives tchèques tony
blair l'ancien premier ministre
britannique mais aussi l'ancien ministre
français et ex directeur du fmi
dominique strauss kahn sont également
cités dans cette enquête mais la
tentation des paradis fiscaux ne touche
pas que le monde politique on retrouve
ainsi les noms de la chanteuse shakira
ou encore du mannequin claudia schiffer
du côté du montant des sommes accumulées
dans les paradis fiscaux là aussi la
somme donne le tournis onze mille 300
milliards de dollars celle estimation
déjà donnée en 2020 par l'eau cd e et il
semblerait que tous ces héros soit
confirmée par l'investigation des
pandora peppers noter que dans la
plupart des pays ces faits ne sont pas
susceptibles d'entraîner des poursuites
mais l' enquête a tout de même mis en
lumière un paradoxe les discours contre
le blanchiment d'argent et l'évasion
fiscales sont souvent tenus par des
personnalités dont le pécule et bien à
l'abri dans des paradis fiscaux